ma sembra un buco nero qualità mentale e
oggi a mio vedere le piscine più assurde
più belle più strane al fondo siete
pronti casa di un blake se potere delle
altre cose strane belle fatte e
mettetevi comodi e poi alla fine del
video si diverte fuori la piscina che vi
è piaciuto più di tutte le partite non
mi cambia la piscina numero ultima
instaurare una piscina in una spiaggia
ora qua invece rapisce una piscina in
una villa c'è la vetrata dentro la casa
bellina quale 6 milano tra la prima e la
seconda sarà presente cosa mi può essere
tese si stanno rilassando pino vicino a
questa casa incredibile tutto
apprendimento e l'ha costruita intorno
alla piscina perché lunga la vicina alla
punta pura allora ragazzi altissimo più
grandi al mondo a stampo san alfonso del
mar in cile
sembra un pezzo di mare che è in grado
praticamente è un complesso di hotel
ma ci sono anche le barchette che vanno
lassina enorme tua ti perdi c'è anche
una piscina net e una piscina quindi
anche con la barca è enorme poi c'è pure
la spiaggia dove lo stupendo 2 ti perdi
proprio su persone est allora passiamo
in svizzera in mezzo alle montagne c'è
questa piscina di acqua calda immagino
sempre stare notavano in mezzo alle
montagne e belli con la leva ma sono
tutti discorsi troppo casi addio al
paesaggio capelli ma questa calda
capolino massaggio anche vedi tutte
quelle bollicina usi ma se producono la
multa apre paura di cadere sotto allora
prossimo vissina è una piscina
tra le sempre ma ci hanno costruito una
sorta di un riso l'auto dentro le
montagne con i bagni la però sembra
molto figlia tutta naturale poi quasi
tutta naturale c'è anche riusciremo
dentro a questa è un'altra piscina in
cui ci sono le onde simulate
spettacolare questo sembra stare in mare
con un super scivolo che belle anche
dell'età anni e un parco divertimenti
piccola piscina quando a londra sto
prendendo tipo di enormi possessivo l'ha
pure una squadra così nel frattempo
contesta a cabras
allora avevamo visto la foto si merita
ti ricordi e della cucina ma una piece
in qui ci sono i coccodrilli entrano
dentro una gabbietta una gabbia e ci
sono dei coccodrilli che tra l'altro
sono giganteschi questi coccodrilli
chiedere il cocco che il cordino beffa
favorirti va tranquillo
è stata una nota il prossimo pessina e
su un palo spesa
no quasi tutti immergi ii e del tutto in
vetro costruendo tube lì sotto oddio che
paura nuovo questa è davvero davvero
paurosa però mi preme più paura quella
per i coccodrilli o vuole fare più paura
per i coccodrilli ma questa in altissimo
casa i due stop per paura che c'erano
all'improvvisa della parte io ti sembra
di camminare venaria
che paura siamo piscina si vogliono
italian che mi vengono gli incubi
attrezzarsi pratica è una piscina super
profonda e tu scendi non mi ricordo
quale era la possibilità bomber su honda
e non lo so mi da un senso di
claustrofobia perché queste super in
profondità e ovviamente dopo un po ti
manca l'ossigeno e di risalire in uno
spazio abbastanza stretti un buco nero
dove i brividi questo addio
io non scenderei la sotto voi avreste il
coraggio di sempre lo stop al buio che
con sonia messina ci sono le persone
sotto magari è solo un pezzo di vetro
con dell'acqua perché milan fretta
questo è divertente prossimo piscina
francamente questa è tipo sembrati cure
di una casa sotto arconi immersa
sott'acqua con le finestre e il turno di
qua sotto non so perché ma anche questo
mi dà un po il senso di claustrofobia
voi che ne pensate se non sbaglio questo
era un hotel a las vegas avevo visto che
va dalle piscine così lo stesso sono
tipo infilato in alto tutti immersi poi
di restare a te per ottenere se vuoi
guardare sotto quale un'altra piscina
mentre le montagne che spero che sia di
acqua calda altrimenti ti punge lì c'è
tutto poi tra l'altro c'è una specie di
laghetto in mezzo alle due montagne
lanese la mia
una provocazione la sfida spettacolare
questa queste persone che nato come sono
tiziano surgelato è perché magari sono
perché c'è il sole caldo e bel a una
piscina a forma di violino o chitarra
violino fiorino perché venissero capita
a chi l'ha costruito deve essere proprio
violinista appassionato anche là
l'asticella della festa vi piace
tantissimo non so perché esistiamo da
pagare se non a pagare alla cucina ma
allora perché la piscina privata di
qualcuno che a questa mega casa e wow
bellissimo anche questa di vetro presto
dell'olio così è la piscina quando
prenderemo in casa lavoro così un'altra
piscina dentro una casa e se un
corridoio un po stanco origine la
piscina sul soffitto quindi notti stop
era la casa molto originale però figo e
procura sacco di lucio e poi di giorni
questo l'hotel che abbiamo visto prima
oh oh mio dio quindi queste sono le
piste ma che forma strana tra l'altro se
ogni istanza alla sua piscina
a genova invece che avranno una grande
per fallire
che non c'entra la paura questa mattina
lo so comunque che figata poi quella che
sta qua in alto arma della lila suite
che paura pero stare quali la nato io
noto anche gli occhi delle foto ma
soprattutto la cosa più importante una
piscina per cani perché anche gli
animali hanno bisogno di divertirsi
avere una fisica per la verifica per lo
bianco sta sta mettendo sotto quello che
ero la flora un'altra piscina
spero caso si si
tutti o troppo la neve la sommerà il
paesaggio spettacolare per questo
effetto si fuori dall'acqua immagini sia
super freddo sul mare sullo share non so
dove stiamo bellissima gigante anche
questa ma un cartello sistina piccola
facciotto però riga dei ragazzi un'altra
piscina bellissimo e mi chiedo sempre in
queste piscine con rischi di camerino
l'infiniti bull praticamente sembra
sembra non si vede una celere sembra di
cadere ma in realtà c'è un muro come
poco più basso dalla lego a 6 il muro
però rischi comunque di telemann sotto
dall'altra parte si stia facoltà
comunque l'ha visto che è ok vediamo con
questa piscina sbaglia stupendo
scommetto che ora avete voglia di estate
di andare in sulla storia di andare al
mare che non partiva
allora primi commenti quale la piscina
che vi è piaciuta più di tutte quella
che mi ha scioccato di più e ora vi
desse avuto a quattro casse lines
cliccare cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona visione